prenons véritablement nos travaux et je
peux vous dire que cet après-midi
l'audition de de Madame Paty de la sœur
de Samuel Paty était particulièrement
poignante un autre sujet ce sont les
atteintes à la laïcité oui et je pense
qu'il y a mission commission que la
commission de l'éducation de la culture
je le proposerai demain nous avons
réunion du bureau demain matin je
proposerai que à côté de la commission
d'enquête qui est liée à l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty il y a un véritable
recensement de la réalité des des
atteintes à laïcité on peut pas mettre
tout sur le même pied d'égalité la
lorsqu'on est sur la commission
d'enquête Samuel Patti il s'agit
d'évoquer ce qui a conduit à un drame
absolu à la mort d'un professeur mais il
y a les multiples atteintes dans la vie
quotidienne des professeurs il y a la
manière dont l'éducation nationale les
traite dont elles sont remontter donc je
crois qu'on a vraement besoin
d'objectiver le sujet miss
groupe vaoser demain matin au bureau de
la commission de l'éducation la culture
du Sénat cette mission d'information
pour y voir plus clair et peut-être
aussi pour faire des propositions sur la
manière d'accompagner les professeurs et
d'apporter une réponse je pense qu'il
manque véritablement aujourd'hui un
véritable plan de lutte contre toutes
les atttes à lacité et contre
l'islamisme radical qui s'attaque à
l'école de
République